su última aparición pública fue el lunes
junto a su homólogo belga el primer
ministro jan castex dio positivo por
kobe 19 y está sufriendo síntomas leves
según su oficina durante los próximos 10
días el jefe de gobierno permanecerá
aislado los 5 funcionarios belgas que
estuvieron en contacto con él tendrán
que guardar una cuarentena a la espera
de los resultados de su prueba pcr jan
castex de 56 años se había vacunado por
primera vez en junio desde el comienzo
de la pandemia ha estado en contacto con
personas positivas por ccoo y 19 en
varias ocasiones durante el tour de
france en septiembre de 2020 y dos meses
después en una cena con manu el maco
el contagio de castex llega en un
momento en el que francia se ha visto
afectada por la quinta ola que crece
rápidamente en una semana el número de
casos diarios casi se ha duplicado cada
día se contabilizan 18.000 nuevos
pacientes